lydia is with us in columbia missouri
hey lydia how are you
fine thank you how are you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
you
um my husband and i are currently
renting
and our rent expires roughly uh by july
this year
we've been planning to buy our own home
and we started listening to your program
less than um two or three months
and um we want to buy our own home
because our kids are here to join us we
are immigrants
i joined my husband about two years ago
in the pandemic
or before the pandemic and i started
working not long ago
our income for the year
is about a hundred and fifty hundred and
sixty my husband makes over a hundred
and i make about thirty thousand
uh we have uh car loans my husband has
student loans
uh we have irs debt our total debt is
125.
uh our question is you've been here he's
been here
three years or you've been here three
years i have been
here two years he has been here 20 years
20
10 10. okay i was thinking man he got
car debt and irs debt pretty quick
okay wow so now
where which uh which country are you
immigrating from
uh ghana africa ghana wonderful and uh
or is this a permanent citizenship or
green card or what
i am on green card he's permanent
resident okay
all right wonderful so you'll be able to
get your citizenship then right
yes yes wonderful awesome well welcome
we're glad you're here
all right and what do you guys do for a
living um
he's a nest and i'm also a nurse as
but i am a medical assistant he's unless
in the
fight field gotcha and how old are your
children
uh our son is 21 uh
daughter is eight fifteen two little
ones
10 and eight and they're all in africa
uh one is here one is my step my husband
had a child out
with someone when he was here without me
and then i have a natural fact
i have two kids he has two back home but
we both are out of our first marriages
so we we have been together less than
five years
i understand okay and the um so you're
you're you could rent a home for the
children that would live in your home
if they were to move here correct yes
okay that's what you need to do you need
to get out of debt first
build your emergency fund of three to
six months of them
expenses second and then
then start saving to buy a home when you
buy a home with all this debt hanging
around your neck and with no emergency
savings
the home will end up being more of a
curse than a blessing
it is not a it is it is home ownership
when you're broke is a bad thing it will
get you it will bite you
um and so you've got you've got good
incomes
uh he has had some bad he's developed
some bad american habits with money
uh i hear them in the mistakes he's made
uh
you may have participated in a couple of
those but you got car debt you got irs
debt you got some other things you need
to clean up here
because that's that's a mess and then
save your emergency fund for a rainy day
and then uh and then do this so what i
want to do is i want to help you with
this because i'm inspired by your story
we have a class called financial peace
university we have a budgeting app
called every dollar
the premium version of every dollar in
financial peace university are all
included in what's called ramsey plus
a one-year membership to that to be able
to watch those videos go through this
financial class you and your husband do
that together
obviously we charge a hundred dollars
for all of that per year
if i give it to you as a gift will you
promise me that you and your husband
will do
everything in there yes you will
i think you might so you hold on and
i'll give it to you kelly will pick up
and we'll get you signed up
um that's pretty cool that's super cool
and i love how you framed that you've
picked up some bad american habits
you don't do that in ghana that's hey
man you don't have irs debt and car debt
in ghana
no it's it's the truth right it's the
truth
it's a it's a cultural thing i mean
there's there are countries that do the
same stupid butt stuff we do australia
they're about as you know uk you know
england about as stupid as we are on
stuff like this
are dumber in some cases but uh
as a culture but um you know you can
observe these things
in different cultures the way people
handle money the way they see money it
has a lot to do with a lot of different
factors economic factors and other
things but
you know what's interesting is if they
get their act together they have a
higher probability of becoming wealthy
than someone that's born here
why do you think that is i think they
believe that it's a land of opportunity
and some of us aren't sure we just don't
believe it anymore we're waiting on
somebody else to do it
and that that all they wanted was a
chance a place that they could do it and
they just see
fields upon fields to go right it's the
the land of opportunity not the land of
entitlement
and uh they see it that way they think
the statue of liberty is real
and um i do because i'm an old-fashioned
american softy
some of the coolest most inspirational
folks i've i've been around in my
in my in my educational career was
international students who'd come over
and say
you're telling me i can get a law degree
here you tell me i can go to med school
you're telling me i can go to walmart
and they have seven kinds of game
on yeah let's do this man this is the
land of abundance yeah yeah
gift upon gift upon gift two aisles of
cookies working
hard hard hard hard yeah what do you
mean you gotta be kidding me
yeah it's it's real